try your best but unfortunately when
you're facing the world champion
who has been well prepared in this
opening um yeah that's never gonna
really work out so
to me it was a slightly overthinking it
perhaps he was
he remembered that he had played a game
against fabiana caruana and he thought
well you know i captured the bishop
there and maybe
i wasn't wasn't too comfortable with the
resulting position
so let's just play something else and
just better to be
slightly worse have a small disadvantage
and survive rather than get checkmated
so brutally i agree um okay
yeah i mean i think both both players
they have been the masters of their own
demise
in the last couple of games so yeah for
sure black is struggling in this match
it's just a struggle to get out of the
opening and nakamura he's just trying to
find one final trick but he just resigns
about to get checkmated magnus carson
looking happy there with the head bob
wow it's a comeback from magnus carlsen
after losing the first game
he's coming back in the second one with
the white pieces winning against ikaro
nakamura